HERE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WILL HAVE TO BE A SUBCOMMITTEE
STARTED [inaudible]
SENATOR PARA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SHARE MEMBER.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT --
SP.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR THE BILL
THAT DIRECTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH AN ADVISER
WHO STUDY THE PROBLEM TO SPREAD
A FALSE INFORMATION THROUGH
INTERFACE INTERNET BASED SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM.
THE DRAFT THE MODELS OF TEACHING
PLAN FOR SUCH PLATFORMS MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
PLATFORMS.
I DO STE SP FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CLEAR ISSUE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SPREAD OF
FALSE INFORMATION.
CERTAINLY IN OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
WORLD -- NOW
WE SEE FIRST ABOUT --
THE EARTH IS FLAT THEN.
SO FOR THAT NAY SEEMS A BIT
AMUSING BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
GOT MORE SERIOUS SIDE YOU HAVE --
DISSEMINATION OF THE HOLOCAUST
DENIAL DENIALS.
SHOOTINGS THAT HAPPENED AT SANDY
HOOK AND PARK LAND WHICH ALSO
RESULTED NOT ONLY JUST YOU KNOW
COST INFORMATION BUT LED.
TO INTIMIDATION AND THREATS --
AND THEN WE EVEN MORE SERIOUSLY
PRONE TO MANIPULATION SO FOR
EXAMPLE SIDE.
AND YOU SAID IT WAS ACTUALLY
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA --
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY SAYS
DIVISIONS --
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT AND
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN SCIENCE
MAGAZINE REPORTED THAT IN
INVESTIGATING THE DIFFERENCE OF
THE FUSION OF ALL VERIFY TRUE
AND FALSE NEWS CHOICE SHOULD.
BETTER BETWEEN 200-062-00017
THAT FALSEHOODS IF YOU
SIGNIFICANTLY FASTER FARTHER AND
DEEPER.
AND MORE BROADLY THE TRUTH IN
ALL CHARACTERS INFORMATION IN
FACT THEY NOTED THAT --
FALSE INFORMATION ACT TO BE
TWICE AS FAR.
AS THAT CHIU INFORMATION.
AND SAID SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES
ARE PLATFORMS FALSE INFORMATION
SPREADS ITS CAN BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS IS HAPPENING.
I KNOW THAT SEVERAL COMPANIES
ARE REALLY TRYING TO COME UP
WITH PLANTS THE DELEGATE THE
SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION THE
PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW WHAT THOSE
PLANS ARE AND HOW THE WORKING.
AND AS A SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES --
TO LET US KNOW IF THEY HAVE.
PLANS ABOUT THOSE CLAIMS ARE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THE SPREAD.
COULD BE A WORK GROUP TO STUDY
RESEARCH PLAN MILES.
STEPPED WORKING TO SLOW THE
SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION I
HOPE WE CAN BETTER PROTECT THE
PUBLIC.
HARM THAT CAN BE CAUSED BY.
BY THESE FALSE STORIES I WOULD
MAKE YOU KNOW THAT.
WHAT WE REALLY ARE LOOKING AT
CERTAINLY WE UNDERSTAND?
THAT PEOPLE THE FIRST.
RIGHT TO POST WHICH UP WHATEVER
THEY WANT.
AND THAT IT CERTAINLY THIS IS
NOT IN ANY WAY. TO LIMIT THE
ABILITY PEOPLE TO POST THINGS ON
SOCIAL BE A BAD THING AT THE END
OF THREE NEVER EARLIER
INNOVATION THAT DEL TERMS OF
QUIETLY YOU CAN'T THIS WORKING
GROUP -- WE
EVEN HAD CHALLENGES TRYING TO
JUST COME OF THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA WAS IN LEGAL
TERMS.
OKAY AND EXACTLY WHAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THAT AND WEBER.
I THINK SOME OF THOSE ISSUES ARE
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE.
I WORKED OUT WITH VERY
STAKEHOLDERS IS VIA A WAY TO
APPROACH THAT WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING SEARCH
TECHNOLOGY --
SO WE INSERT THE REGULAR MEDIA
THERE ARE MECHANISMS BOB IN
PLACE TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
WHILE STILL ALLOWING FIRST
AMENDMENTS.
RIGHTS AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO BE SURE WE PROTECT FIRST
AMENDMENT SPEECH RIGHTS BUT WE
ALSO DON'T WANT TO TECHNOLOGY
THAT -- THAT.
THAT IS DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY --
TO IN THE WAYS THAT CAN BE
HARMFUL TO OUR SOCIETY THAT THAT
DAY GO TO TERMS OF DISSEMINATION
SO.
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE EXAMINED QUARTERLY TO
PROTECT IF MARKETS SEE THAT'S
WHAT THIS CALL'S ABOUT
APPRECIATE.
PASSWORD I GREAT --
VOTE TAKE A MOTION WHO DO HAVE A
QUORUM NOW.
AND ALSO WANT TO INTRODUCE OUR
NEW MEMBER A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SYDNEY.
A CALM THE CAR DOGS.
SHE I'D UNDERSTAND SHE REPRESENT
A TOOL OF GOOD LARGE --
STUDIOS BOASTS A SONY AND
PARAMOUNT SO PLEASE JOIN ME
WELCOME --
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER SYDNEY COLOR.
COM LUCK CAR COME LAGER.
KAMLAGER-DOVE RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY.
AND FONG WHILE OKAY GREAT.
SO I'M EVIDENCE SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU HERE KANSEN CHU HERE
WALDRON.
WALDRON HERE ACOSTA HEAR THE
CONSTANT HERE DAVID CHIU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE MS AREA.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
OWNED AS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHOWN SANDRA PANDAS TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
OVER BACK TO TO THE DOW'S ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
DURING THOSE WELL HAVE A MOTION.
AND WILL HAVE A SAGA
[inaudible]
IN.
SO BY I JUST POINT WOULD JUST A
A WHOLE DO BILL AND TWO WE HAVE.
MORE OF A MEMBER JOINED US
ACCOUNT FOR THE NEW BUT THIS --
THIS BILL DOES HE ENJOYED A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU DOCTOR FAT
[inaudible]
LEYVA
AND NTER Y.
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MOVES OUTSIDE
[inaudible]
MAS NDA [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
SENATOR ANDERSON
[inaudible]
EXECUTIVE EXPERIENCE
YEAH HELLO [inaudible]
JOSH'S [inaudible]
QUESTION [inaudible]
BLUSHING
[inaudible]
NNAMDI [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH
[inaudible]
SHE SERVICE [inaudible]
PHONE.
THERE ARE SOME [inaudible]
WHAT'S.
JERRY.
CHAIR WAS
[inaudible]
TODAY'S
SO [inaudible] TO BE
[inaudible]
THE VOICES.
IN MANY INSTANCES [inaudible]
NNOVA.
HE WAS A FUNNY SONG SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
THE PROBLEM.
I WANTED TO HEAR [inaudible]
THEY
HAVE
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL ANY [inaudible]
STARTED [inaudible]
ORIGIN
[inaudible]
SAN JOSE
.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU WILL GROW
SENATOR ANDERSON IN THE HOUSE.
PERCENT S. C. ARE [inaudible]
ONE TWENTY ONE SENATOR.
THANKS VERY MUCH --
S. C. AREN'T ONE TWENTY ONE
RECOGNIZES AND HONORS THE
HISTORY AND SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
LEGAL STAFF HERE'S THE FIRST
FLAG OF THE AMERICAS.
OF THE SOVEREIGN NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL NATIONS IN THE FIRST
NATION'S REPRESENTS TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY UNITY INTRODUCTIONS
AND IS A PROUD LEGACY OF THE
INTEGRITY IN HONOR OF NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AYE MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRIS LYNCH
FROM WITH CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
BUSINESS ALLIANCE WERE IN
SUPPORT.
OF ALSO HERE --
FOR PAHLAVI IN THAT MISSION
INDIANS THE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE THEY'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER ANDERSON AND MISS WALDRON
HIS A PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR --
THE PLAN IS.
TO THE COMMITTEE PERMITTING OF
COURSE OF THE LEGISLATURE
PERMITTING IS TO HAVE THIS
RESOLUTION PRESENTED TO THE
NATIONAL GATHERING.
OF NATIVE AMERICANS IN CHICAGO
LATER THIS MONTH --
PAUL UP SANS A DELEGATION OF
NATIVE AMERICAN VETERANS --
TO THIS GATHERING EVERY YEAR AND
THEIR LIKE TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION THIS EVENT HONORS ALL
VETERANS.
NATIVE AND NON NATIVE ALLY IN
ITS A THEY LIKE TO DO IT IN
INDIAN STYLE FRANKLY SOME RAIN
THAT DOES GOOD ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
AND WHAT THE IMPACT OF THE DAY
AS WELL ANY COMMON QUESTIONS --
MR ACOSTA THANK YOU AS CHAIR
ENOUGH THANK YOU CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND NOW
PALLA FOR YOU KNOW THE
SPONSORING THAT LEGISLATION.
OUT GREAT STUFF AS A SON OF A ON
ARMY VETERAN AND YOU KNOW MANY
OF US LATINOS HAVE A NATIVE
AMERICAN BACKGROUND WE'RE
CERTAINLY PLEASED TO SEE THIS
OTHERS COME FORWARD.
AND I'D CERTAINLY LIKE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND THANK YOU.
WOULD ANY OTHER MEMBERS LIKE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR.
ROUGHLY HALF GIVE ME.
TO ABSOLUTELY NO GREAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE
COMMON.
AND WOULD DO HAVE A MOTION BY
ACOSTA.
AND AND SECONDS TO HAVE A QUORUM.
WE DO IT WE WELCOME KALRA OKAY.
I AM PLEASED CALDERON.
KANSEN CHU AYE KANSEN CHU AYE
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
ACOSTA.
THE CONCERT NINE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
MS ARYAN.
OR I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THINKING
VERY MUCH YOU.
FLORIDA A HERTZBERG MORE
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HOUSE FOR IT [inaudible]
OKAY AREA [inaudible]
GO.
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS PRETENDING
SP ONE ZERO THEIR WATCHED
[inaudible]
THEY CAN [inaudible]
* THAT. ONE ZERO ZERO ONE
THERE'S HARMONY AND THAT NAME
ITS ONES AND ZEROS THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ONES AND
ZEROS.
BECAUSE ONE'S AND ZEROS ARE
CHANGE IN THE WORLD ONES AND
ZEROS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA
THIS IS ABOUT BOTS.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
BASICALLY IN A NUTSHELL WITH
THIS BILL IS TO HAVE TRUTH.
IN HOW THE INTERNET IS USED TO
CREATE DECEPTION.
WHETHER IT'S IN THE AREA OF
POLITICS JUST HAPPEN TO BE IN MY
ALEXIAN THIS VERY LAST TIME IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
WE SEE IT IN BUSINESSES WHERE
COMPANIES ARE SAYING THEY'VE GOT
SO MANY FOLLOWERS.
AND WE SEE THAT WERE CELEBRITIES
COME IN AND GO HIGHER COMPANIES.
WE DON'T WANT NO I KNOW THERE'S
A QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED
APPROPRIATELY SO MORE SENSITIVE
TO WHAT ABOUT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES IN THE ANALYSIS.
THE ISSUE IS NOT WHAT TO BE SAID
BUT THAT PEOPLE THAT WHEN YOU
TRY TO FAKE IT.
WHEN YOU TRY TO CREATE THE
IMPRESSION THAT YOU'RE TALKING
TO A HUMAN BEING?
YOU'RE DOING THAT TO DECEIVE
SOMEBODY NOT IN THE NATURE OF
YOUR MESSAGE BUT WHO IS THE
MESSENGER.
AND SO THIS BOTS BILL IS TO US
IS A BIG DEAL WITH COMMON SENSE
TO SPONSOR WILL DO LET THEM TALK
IN A MINUTE.
BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT THIS ISSUE
OF JUST DISCLOSURE THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IN SOME
REASONABLE METHODS OF
ENFORCEMENT.
SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW THAT WHEN
SOMEBODY SAYS IT'S KANSEN CHU ON
THE LINE IT'S NOT REALLY YOU ITS
JUST A NOTIFICATION THAT IF
SOMEBODY SAYS THAT THERE YOU
COULD BE BOOK.
LAST POINT I'LL MAKE.
FUNDAMENTAL THE CONSTITUTION IS
ANONYMITY.
THE FEDERALIST PAPERS THE FOLKS
THAT WROTE THAT THEY DID HAVE
THEIR NAMES ON IT THOMAS PAINE
DIDN'T NAMES ON COMMON SENSE
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE.
BUT WE KNEW IT WAS SOME HUMAN
BEING.
THAT WAS BEHIND IT RATHER THAN
SOME.
KNOWLEDGE THE IN A DECEPTIVE WAY
AND UNDER THE LAW THERE'S A
BASIC CONT THERE'S A BASIC RIGHT
THAT IS IN CONFLICT WITH THE
RIGHT OF FREE SPEECH.
AND THAT IS THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT TEND NOT TO FRAUD TO BE
FREE OF THE FRAUD.
IS ALL THROUGHOUT THE LAW IS A
CRIME AGAINST FRAUD THAT'S ALL
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET JUST
SAY WHAT YOU WANT.
WE DON'T CARE JUST LET US KNOW
THAT IT'S DONE THROUGH A
COMPUTER --
WHO'S TRYING TO IMPERSONATE A
HUMAN BEING ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE AND
FOR LETTING ME BRIEFLY ADDRESS
YOU MY NAME'S SEAN PRESTON AND
FORMER DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE A
LIFELONG HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVIST
AND NOW A SENIOR ADVISER TO
COMMONSENSE MEDIA.
WHY DOES THE KIDS ORGANIZATION
CARE ABOUT POTS HE WOULD QUITE
REASONABLY ASKING YOURSELF?
AND THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE EVERY
PARENT WANTS TO LEAVE A BETTER
OFF WORLD FOR THEIR KIDS THAN
THEY FOUND THEN THEY CAME INTO
THEM.
AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION ABOUT BOTS
THAT MAKES ME VERY WORRIED THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
ON IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
WE'VE ALL GONE ON A ON A
LEARNING JOURNEY ABOUT WHAT BOTS
ARE AND HOW THIS USE OF
FRAUDULENT.
AUTOMATED ACCOUNTS ONLINE CAN BE
USED TO MANIPULATE PUBLIC
OPINION.
AND THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT I
WANT TO BRING UP THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
ONE IN EVERY HUMAN RIGHTS
SITUATION AROUND THE WORLD EVERY
MAJOR HUMAN RIGHTS SITUATION.
POTS OF BEING USED BY
AUTHORITIES IN POWER TO OPPRESS
THEIR PEOPLE POLITICAL ACTIVISTS
IN CAMBODIA ARE BEING TRACKED
DOWN BY BOTS.
JOURNALISTS IN KENYA ARE BEING
TRACKED DOWN BY BOUGHT SOMETHING
IT'S POISONING PUBLIC DISCOURSE
IN AFRICA IN MEXICO HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS ARE BEING.
TRACKED DOWN AND TARGETED BY BUT
SOMETIMES BOUGHT NETWORKS OF
TENS OF THOUSANDS OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAKE ACCOUNTS THAT
WILL BE TARGETED TOWARDS ONE
SMALL GRASSROOTS.
ACTIVIST SO THAT'S THE HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUE THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT WE'RE ALL VERY AWARE OF IS
THE ELECTION HACKING ISSUE I
WISH I COULD SAY THAT WERE
BEHIND US IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR UNITED STATES DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DANIEL
COATS.
ADDRESSED THE U. S. CONGRESS AND
SAID IT IS ONGOING ANY SAID
SPECIFICALLY IT'S FAKE NEWS AND
THOUGHTS THAT ARE BEING USED TO
ATTACK ELECTIONS.
A RESEARCHER FROM THE RESEARCH
DIRECTOR AT THE DITCH INTEL LAB
AT THE INSTITUTE FOR THE FUTURE
PAL WHAT DOMAIN NAME SAMUEL
WILLIE.
WHO STUDIES THE SAYS THAT IN
ALMOST?
TODAY YOU CAN SEE BOTS
ATTEMPTING TO MANIPULATE THE
PUBLIC DISCOURSE --
SO WE HAVE THIS HUMAN RIGHTS
PROBLEMS WE HAVE THESE ELECTION
PROBLEMS BOTH OF WHICH ARE
VARIOUS VERY SERIOUS.
NOW A LIBERTARIAN VIEWPOINT
MIGHT LOOK AT THIS AND SAY --
AN ARGUMENT SIMILAR TO GUNS
DON'T KILL PEOPLE PEOPLE KILL
PEOPLE AND THAT'S A SEMANTIC
ARGUMENT MAY BE TRUE OR NOT BUT
WHAT IS TRUE IS WE NEED A STRONG
WEB OF REGULATIONS.
AROUND GUN CONTROL WE NEED
STRONG GUN REGULATIONS THAT
SOMETHING THE STATE VERY CLEARLY
BELIEVES THAT.
SIMILARLY BOTS ARE BEING USED TO
KILL PEOPLE AND ATTACK OUR
DEMOCRACY NEED STRONG
REGULATIONS IT'S NOT GONNA COME
OUT OF CONGRESS HAS A COMMITTED
THE TECH INDUSTRIES.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU ALL WILL
JOIN IN THAT EFFORT.
THANK YOU AND YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WAS THAT WOULD ASSIST IN SUPPORT.
BUT HE'S TRYING TO FIX A
MICROPHONE LA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OR ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WILL READ [inaudible]
GOSH OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RUSLAN ABOUT IT
WITH TECH THAT WE HAD OPPOSE
LET'S AMENDED POSITION WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF DILIGENTLY TO GET US TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION WE HAVE ONE
LAST ISSUE TO WORK OUT WHICH IS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS.
HAVING TO DO WITH THE
FEASIBILITY OF CLEAR CONSPICUOUS
NOTICE AND WE HOPE THAT WAS ALL
THAT SOON THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AYE SARAH BOOT ON BEHALF
OF CAL CHAMBER I WANNA ECHO
EXACTLY THE SENTIMENTS RACE BY
TECHNO AND TO SAY THANK YOU TO
AUTHOR FOLLOWS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU --
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
S. FREEMAN.
SORRY THAT OF PRESIDENT I'D LIKE
TO BE OUT ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
NO GREAT THANK YOU.
PERFECT.
THANK THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL COMMENT QUESTIONS.
ON THIS JOHN SP NIGH.
NO SEEN NO.
STICK CLOSE AGE THAT TO SAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN TWO THINGS ONE
IS THAT.
YOU KNOW THE PARKLAND SHOOTING
HAPPENED SOME MONTHS AGO AND
LITERARY WITHIN HOURS OVER.
SIX HUNDRED BOTS WE'RE TRYING TO
AGITATE ON BOTH SIDES IS IN A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE VERSUS THE
WEATHER BUT THE RUSSIANS A LOT
OF REALLY ACTIONABLE DARIEN'S
WHAT THEY DO IS.
IF THEY CREATE ACTIVITY WHERE
PEOPLE WILL FOLLOW AND THEY SAY
AND CENTURY THINGS.
THEY GET PAID FOR HOW MANY HOW
MANY WHAT VIEWS THEY GET AND SO
YOU'LL SEE THIS NOT JUST FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES BUT FOR BURE
ECONOMIC INTERESTS THAT HAPPENED
REALLY PART ONE WAS JUST A GREAT
EXAMPLE.
WHERE THAT LOUIS WERE SIX
HUNDRED OF THESE THINGS ON BOTH
SIDES JUST CREATE NOISE?
LAST THING I JUST WANT TO SAY AS
A MATTER OF KIND OF PERSONAL
INTEREST IS I CREATED THIS
COMMITTEE SOME TWENTY YEARS AGO
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT.
AND I KNOW THIS THAT THEY ADDED
ON IN THERE INTERNET MEDIA IT
TOWARDS THE TIME GOING FORWARD
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE
WITH THE SPOTS BILL.
IT'S KINDA INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT THAT ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL I REPEAT
AGAIN DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
FOR S. B. SECOND I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR S. B..
NINE S. B.. NINE ONE ZERO AS WE
EVER HAVE A MOTION.
THIS IS.
ONE ZERO ZERO WHAT'S DIFFERENT.
KNOWN AS A SPECIAL SOMEONE.
YOU I'M JUST USING THE BINARY
NUMBER --
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE IN BINARY
NUMBER IS [inaudible]
NINE SO YOU.
LEAVE US BUT IN DECIMAL THIS FBI
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE I HOPE WE WILL
HAVE.
YEAH.
WAY OVER OUR YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU SIR WOULD YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND THEN
SENT THROUGH DO PLEASE CALDERON
GOOD.
ABSOLUTELY ONE ZERO CLIMATE
HERTZBERG DO YOU PASSED ON
FAMILY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
KANSEN CHU AYE KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
MS AREA ON THIS AREA ON YOUR
SHALL WORK REAL EARLY
[inaudible]
NOT NOW.
ONLY WHEN I HAVE THREE OKAY
ALTHOUGH.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU REALLY.
THANK YOU MADAM COOPER.
THANK YOU MY SETTLEMENT
.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PM.
DE PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
NO WE WITH CAN ALL KNOW WE NEED
TO THINK [inaudible]
OKAY FLORA.
LOOKING.
BACK OPEN AND S. B. --
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR TENNIS
FREMONT MAKE A MOTION AND OF
THEIR RANSACKING.
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
KANSEN CHIU AYE KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
NO WE DIDN'T HAVE A WE DON'T
HAVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
MS AREA.
THIS VERY NIGHT IT'S STILL ON
OKAY SO. FOURTEEN TWENTY OF
FORTY TWENTY FOURS ON CALL.
WILL MOVE ON TO AT C. ARE
[inaudible]
ONE TWENTY ONE SENATOR ANDERSON.
OKAY XCR [inaudible]
ONE TWENTY ONE NURSE AREA.
THIS AREA I MANILA.
JUST A DAY
.
YEAH IT'S ACTUALLY BROKEN.
THE LAST GROUP [inaudible]
YEAH
.
S. B. [inaudible]
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE ACOSTA
[inaudible]
ACOSTA NO.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
ACOSTA [inaudible]
ACOSTA NO
.
YES IT IS.
WELL HAVE MOVIE IS.
YEAH.
PERFECT AT ONE OF RIO'S
[inaudible]
LOS ANGELES [inaudible]
I MEAN [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
LOOK.
I WAS.
RIGHT.
I APPRECIATE RIGHT RIGHT JUST
YEAH I'M COLLEGE GUYS --
I WAS THE ONLY ONE IN COMMITTEE
UNITED [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT IS WE WILL HELP WITH THAT
LOS WHAT LAW CENTER OPENS.
THAT IS HOW WE CALL THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET PEOPLE THE CONTROL OF NEW
MICROPHONE THAT'S THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT S. BE NOT
FIVE ONE OF VERSION THREE POINT
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE FILM
AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION ACT.
BOB VERY QUICKLY --
YOU KNOW THAT --
EXTENSION OF THAT FILM TAX CUT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AYE WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT IT WILL REMAIN THERE AS THE
GOVERNOR WILL.
UNDOUBTEDLY FIND THE BUDGET AT
SOME POINT --
THIS WEEK I ONE ADDRESSED TO
ISSUES RAISED WITH ME BY THE
CHAIR TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT OUR
INTENTION OF THE BILL --
THE FIRST IS THAT DRAFTING AIR
THAT DID NOT INCLUDE THE NEW
UPLIFT ON WAGES FOR THOSE
WORKING LIVING OUTSIDE OF THE LA
ZONE. 5% FOR INDIES IN
RELOCATING TV SERIES THE FIRST
YEAR AND 10% FOR THE OTHER
PRODUCTIONS THIS BILL ALSO DOES
INCLUDE SOME LANGUAGE THAT WE
DID GUARANTEE GOT INTO THE
TRAILER BILL MISTER CHAIR --
LANGUAGE IT CAME FROM THE API
CAUCUS AND IT WAS JUST A MATTER
OF TIMING THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
AMENDED INTO.
OUR BILL ON BUT I AM COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS ISSUE
STATES FRONT CENTER WHERE ASK
THAT THIS BILL BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE --
JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
FUND BUDGET YET YOU'RE ON BUT I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND WOULD DO
HOW A MOTION AND A SECOND AND I
HAVE A WITNESSES HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE VERY BRIEF
REMARKS AND SUPPORT HIGH OFFERED
THEM TO OF PERCENT OF BEFORE YOU.
SHOW UP.
HANDED DOWN [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT TERRY THOMAS ON BEHALF OF
THE MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA AND ALSO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF THEATER OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA.
SOMEWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I THINK.
THOSE SENATORS OBVIOUS EXPLAINED
WHAT THE REASON IS FOR
CONTINUING WITH THIS BILL AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THINKING.
MR JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THIS VEHICLE.
I ASKED FOR A NIGHT OUT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM INDIA.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL --
THAT LEAD COUNSEL DID BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION THERE'S SOME.
CONFLICT DO WE GIVE THEM WAS TO
SENATE BUDGET BILL.
EIGHT SEVENTY ONE SO I'M I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT YOU HAVE TO
COMMITMENT [inaudible] TO
CONTINUE MOVED TO BAIL TOWARD A
A I THINK REVENUE AND TAX BE OUR
NEXT COMMITTEE.
AND THEN APPROPRIATIONS SO WE
CAN RESOLVE ALL DO A CONFLICT IN
IN THE NEXT.
TO COME COMEY HE'S SO OF WOOD
WAS FAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL M. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY ONE
MITCHELL D. PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
AND TAXATION.
KANSEN CHU AYE KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA.
I'D THE CONSTANT AYE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
MS ARYAN.
I AM VERY AND I ALRIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR.
THE BILL OF REBELS OUT THING
LAURIE MY VIDEO PHONE FIVE OR
EARLY I APPRECIATE YOUR PAY
ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WELL
.
SURE VOTES AND I KNOW
[inaudible]
IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
IF I YOU DON'T NEED ME.
AND I THINK SOME OF THE STUFF WE
SHOULD BE BACK.
HERE IN A MOMENT.
YOU'RE WELCOME I JUST.
HOUSE WAITING TO SEE IF SHE
TEXTS ME BACK LIKE A ONE HOUR
[inaudible]
THE FAA
.
S. B. NINE FIFTY ONE MITCHELL
COME MARGARET.
AYE FROM MARGARET AB I S. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO ONE HERTZBERG
KAMLAGER-DOVE ON AYE FROM LOCKER
THAT I S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR PAN KAMLAGER-DOVE.
COM WATER DEPTH I AND XCR.
ONE TWENTY ONE ANDERSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I YEAH ONLY.
GOOD ANOTHER DOCUMENT ALRIGHT
MEETING ADORN